finally some fish they've worked four
days for this haul the Fisher's have
been doing this job their whole lives
here off the coast of Punta Cana in the
east of the Dominican Republic they used
to make good money doing this life was
better before things are getting harder
and harder fishing isn't the same as it
used to be here business is really bad
at first glance this looks like a decent
catch but ten years ago it would have
been twice the size the reason lies here
the entire coast of the Dominican
Republic is lined with coral reefs
around 90 percent of them have either
died or a severely damaged
the water temperature is rising because
of climate change
this makes the corals weaker and more
vulnerable to pollution and human
activity this is how everything looks
above the surface mass tourism
[Music]
the country attracts six and a half
million visitors every year the tourism
industry consumes huge amounts of
resources and takes its toll on the
wildlife here ironically it's destroying
the things that many tourists come for
in the first place
[Music]
hardly anyone knows this but about 80%
of the typical white sands of the
Caribbean are actually the white
skeletons of corals have healthy reefs
and we don't have healthy corals we're
in danger of losing all these beautiful
things even the white sands and that in
the very places where tourism is the
main source of income oh so let's say la
première printing dresses marine
biologist samantha mercado is working to
preserve the reefs in the lab she breeds
corals for experimental purposes there
later be transferred to a reef we've
discovered that a coral grows faster if
it's divided up into small fragments
rather than left in one big piece it
uses this disk like a prosthesis the
coral wraps itself around it as if it
were its own skeleton the corals can
grow up to ten centimeters a year using
this method up to four times faster than
they would in nature the staff removes
the algae and sand from them on a daily
basis it's usually several months before
they're ready to be released into the
sea the lab is financed by a group of
investors who own a range of hotels in
the country German grants also help to
fund their work we can see which species
are most resistant to high or low
temperatures
or too low sunlight or to other
parameters like an excess of nutrients
other species of coral require different
breeding methods several times a week
Samantha and her colleagues take a boat
out to the coral gardens they've planted
in the open sea the coral we're working
with today is called staghorn coral it
used to be the dominant species here
it's really sad when you think about it
we're transplanting coral and places
that used to be covered in it with a
hammer and some pliers in hand they
plunge four meters below the surface the
corals they've planted here are growing
along a grid
once the tentacles have reached 15
centimeters they can be broken off
researchers use them to help restore the
destroyed reef the growth of the curls
is precisely documented the tentacles
are literally nailed to the reef nine
thousand corals have been attached to
the reef so far about 70% of them have
survived
it's a success for the team but they
maintain that we should be acting
proactively rather than reactively
about 25 percent of the world's marine
life depends on coral reefs mr. Rondeau
we can restore the reef but if we don't
change our mindset if we don't start
using less plastic if we don't start
using detergents that contain less
phosphates and if we don't start
recycling better then all our work here
won't make that much difference in soil
addressed our ASEAN by Sarah Pocock the
team hopes to expand their work over the
coming years they want to restore more
reefs and extend marine protection zones
but the continued growth of tourism will
inevitably pose a challenge
you